tutela tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi di sono fa vj per oggi
siamo tornati su and the sleep allora
rimasti ragazzi al capitano 4 che è
perfetto che ancora non ho capito perché
ci sono fitti con l'inter ma non importa
diamanti regalo tanto ciocchetti che
posso stringere nel dubbio
dove devo arrivare perché non sa figu
sto coso la vera che ancora oggi
perfetto su una porta qua dovrei sì sì
minchia peggio di indiana jones iii che
non chiedetevi come ho fatto a trovare
il passaggio lega ma li trovo ovunque
così qui si sta giocando la foto non so
dove stiamo andando ma non importa in
mezz'ora che fino al caldo da voi
filieri picchiare su sto coso che mi sta
sulle palle abbassati ma come messo le
mutande ok ok io io io salgo sul
cassetto mi spiega perchè c'è un
cassetto che sembra la cassa del
supermercato regalo non so che cazzo
abbia avuto richiamo a qualcosa di forze
g stime più forte di questo è che metta
posto staccando le ragazze sono gomme di
automobili palle da tennis e va beh
giochiamo col comodino giuro che nei
periodi in cui la mia camera fa più
schifo non raggiunge questi livelli ed è
grave la siamo andati da un messi da
schifo cos'era sta roba
io ho un secchio io io ho un [ __ ]
secchio permesso c'è qualcuno c'è
nessuno qui l'ho visto ho visto lurido
siamo di qui siamo di cos'è sta merda
che ha cagato a terra p a legarmi sto
pagando addosso non so
giorgio ros con ansia che non avete idea
oddio mio santo che temete sto schifo io
non ho idea di chi sia mosso prima ma
qualcuno si è moscow sesto schifo
devo infilarci il pene qua dentro cos'è
sta roba cosa devo fare qui perché c'è
una culla sul soffitto si dorme là
dentro baby spider man fermi fermi che
ho trovato se si trovasse calmi
io ho vinto e come i [ __ ] non
entrano netapp e caponetto finito c'era
un tizio un po alto che è passato di
coma non importa io ho trovato un pezzo
di luna il filo qui dentro anche se non
ho capito cosa mi sale ma ecco perfetto
se questi cattivi che c'è una porta che
si apre con un pezzo di luna c'è gente
che si muove mentre io non guardo la
cosa non mi piace farmi dov'è andato o
dovrei trovare in teoria la stella da
metterla dentro credo spero perché sono
non solo non so dove andare seriamente
ragazzi ma che cambi che trova una palla
una falla una palloni poi io vado avanti
me ne frego di ste cose perché non
ma cosa sarebbe kasami all'inizio solo
un inversione molto più tetra di così
c'è una mela c'è una mela e non ho paura
di usa c'è mira dimenticarmi che ce la
fa sono un bambino ma ciò la forza di
lanciare la mela si prega di prato con
dio
cos'è concluso è successo madonna che
ansia dai se se solo farmi sembra
impossibile che ci hanno fatto rendiamo
indietro e anche veloci abbastanza biden
hai buttato giù il muro regali cercate
successo sto a passare di qua e no è no
è no permesso kurt lauk cazzo è stato
sta succedendo rico per per favore che
qualcuno ci fa tiro a bersaglio qui
davvero qualcuno fuori di sinistro non
d'azzardo non tanto a dare aprile non ti
azzardare c'è il dosaggio amico io sono
tanti assaggiato il mio destro perfetto
le ditte la vedete anche voi regala una
magia
grazie e anche se lui la porta è molto
gentile poi via una saponetta ciò che è
stata la infilo nel capro anzi quando
meno te l'aspetti ok ok ha funzionato
ragazzo è cagato addosso arriva il
potere della saponetta vince su tutto
mi spiega perchè c'è una testa attaccata
un comodino attaccato un soffitto
beh sì ma io sono un deficiente perché
quando vado avanti sto gioco sembra che
mi debba stuprare qualcuno da un momento
all'altro ce l'ha fatta
togliti dalle palle ma sto bambino c'è
la stessa agilità di un bradipo
sovrappeso ok perfetto per fare chiunque
fosse sparito ferro per sempre perché
non ci torno più va dentro [ __ ]
noi siamo perché ci sta roba nera
ovunque vado ancora non l'ho capito
ok se un inizio perfetto bene ok non
voglio più sentire parlare di sto posto
di merda me ne vado alla wine vacanze
c'è una tipa senti donna già che non mi
ha fatto vedere le tette d'amico alla
quale prima che che per quel tizio
arrivi e mi faccia del male perché
voglio andarmene via di qua poiché
aiutato non ho chiuso la porta quindi
muoviamoci prima che qualcuno entri a
che non mi fai vedere le tette almeno da
mi sta roba e ci leviamo dalle palle
tutti quanti felici e contenti grazie
abbiamo l'ultimo ricordo sbrighiamoci ok
dottor dove vado non è difficile
no anni quali qua di qua perfetto
porca merda cosa è successo no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no non è ma sono un deficiente
anch'io c'era un [ __ ] buco a terra
uno cosa ho preso lo sapevo che dovevo
chiudere le porte comunque io l'avevo
detto
cazzo no no sì come cazzo fate entrare
no no no no no no no no no no no è
massei bastardo note di master di [ __ ]
è mio è mio no mollate di brutto pezzo
di merda molla nulla con la boston culo
note di non me lo tocchi un pezzo di
merda no unito dove sono un braccio di
teddy è l'unico ricordo che ho del mio
grandissimo amico tutto buio non me ne
frega un cazzo fatti avanti lui fatti
avanti che mi hai siete voi cos'è un
interrogatorio questo sta succedendo
liga questo siamo centro mamma no cosa
non ora cosa vieni qui lurida [ __ ]
pieni e coccola mi ha bisogno di affetto
speranza di merda perché non è se n'è
andata anche mia mamma mi ha abbandonato
chiunque ho detto non ora ho detto
adesso ma ripensandoci delle sue tette
non me ne frega più un cazzo che bella
che poi non c'è nessun chestanno andava
addirittura tesoro anche gli store è
buono adesso la mamma avuto una
giornataccia
ok io io so buono però tu non mi
stuprare che è il bene
ho detto non mi stuprare per favore vedo
perché dove è sparita per favore vai da
qualche altra parte ne prendo solo un
altro forte di quel che cazzo vuoi ma
non rompermi le palle
una donna non gli permettono di portati
via da me prima di questo è un incubo
come parole credo
e quanto la mia mente intelligentissima
possa capire che che tutto quello potete
accendere due luci in croce per favore
non chiedo tanto a siamo ok ok ok ci
siamo ragazzi e la casa non l'avevo
riconosciuta perfetto perché io voglio
vivere qua dentro non e non uscirà mai
più
chiudete mia chiave [ __ ] dovrei
dovremmo essere a posto in teoria se
tutto va come deve andare sembra
impossibile essere arrivato fino a sto
punto ragazza che cosa ok ci siamo ve lo
dico c'è anche se qualcuno mi spuntata
la porta mi incazzo come non so cosa ok
ce l'abbiamo tutti mancano anche a te di
che però non c'è come cazzo fa ha già il
braccio chi dovrebbe funzionare ci siamo
ho finito adesso non scassate vi le
palle a me proprio cagare la porta
dietro pure che entri qualcuno mar ma
facciamo finta di niente perché sempre
tutto buio porca merda posso neanche
stringerete di per far luce perché non
c'ho telli maledizione costò permesso a
madonna e jesus è il tuo ci torna
si legga ci siamo sono tornato a casa a
perfetto dopo anni di cammino però il
problema è che manca teddy e ted era il
mio migliore amico
l'unico che avevo in merci deraa tutti
non so chi è stato a buttare portando
inviate di ma vi giuro che gli farò del
male fisico proprio a qua ci sono dato
tutti i pezzi che incontrato nei miei
sogni
quindi era proprio un sogno ma il
problema è che come ho fatto a dormire
nell'armadio c'è dio dio
ok mamma mamma vieni qui è di tennis e
no vieni quinta di molla lo molla lo
mollò subito ma la tengo me ne frega un
cazzo sei alcuni data ma devi mollare
the di subito ok ma ma ma è tutto a
posto
e tutto a posto ai file delle tette una
storia strappalacrime una lacrima
strappa storie
però io te di melo ripiglio me ne frega
una seria non mi toccare [ __ ] roja
scusate volevo dire
mi dispiace non volevo no no stai
tranquillo adesso ti picchio io posso
prendere questo tirarglielo addosso
mamma ha bussato qualcuno è comunque
cioè non so chi è stato ma qualcuno ha
bussato avrò io apro io che sono un
bravo bimbo giorno è mamma è in cucina
comunque non so chi possa uscire uscire
subito
ecco qua la mia piccina vieni è però sia
il papa perché sono è piaciuto il regalo
che sia successo al braccio non ti
preoccupare lo aggiusteremo e via è
sentita ed il tuo braccio tornerà a
posto c'è bel finale fantastico che la
mamma era alcolizzata inconsciamente era
tutto un sogno della bambina perché la
mamma era alcolizzata quindi quindi non
faceva vedere le tette tutti ragazzi che
dire vi ringrazio per aver seguito la
serie ovviamente ora negli 0 al 3 anche
belle pesanti horror però le tre voi
stessi non vi sbagliano nulla come ha
scelto ragazzi se il video è piaciuto il
suo documento mi piace anche a per
gianni facebook e come nani video plate
nella descrizione se ne sono visti di
scrivetemi ci rimettiamo il prossimo
video belle ragazze